ciao MA Timothy Allen makes a chow mein
Timothy chalahe may why does that sound
not as cool as Timothy Hashanah may no
Tigers my name is grace Helbig if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now the SAG Awards happened
over the weekend
it stands for Screen Actors Guild not
sorry Aunt Grace you weren't invited
again award fancy beautiful people wore
fabrics and other elements of fashion so
let's review it we're making quite the
statement today statement that's we
don't want to be offensive and also come
on dogs to feel comforted that they're
seeing the exact same color scheme of
your fashions that humans are I'm so
thoughtful let's jump right into these
sad carpet fashions sad carpet saggy
carpet that's a fashion statement as
always what these fashion reviews
there's a caveat that there was a ton of
amazing actors at this award show I will
definitely not get all the people that
you might want to talk about so I'm
sorry Gina Rodriguez oh you look like
you're wearing like a mosquito net that
got just like full of nymphs and
butterflies and you're just like no time
to shake it out let's wrap it around and
here's our gaap body bra you Timnath -
Alemanni
I don't care if that's not how you say
it that's how do you say it he looks
like a young James Dean I feel weird the
feeling's I have when I see Timothy
shell make it look so suave and young
and hip and cool he's so cool that he's
like the kind of guy that if you like
thought a cigarette was a candy
cigarette he just straight-up ate it in
front of you you'd be like that's a
great idea
also I'm new in late 2000 and late teens
to Timothy sha'lame because I only just
watch call me by your name last night I
got so hopped up on this movie last
night that I started doing all my
research after I finished checking up on
all Timothy Allen a social media
profiles I then looked at the film which
I found out his based on a 2007 novel
called call me by your name and not only
that it is available in audiobook form
voiced by Armie Hammer who if you don't
know plays Oliver in the film which is
love interest of Timothy shell amaze no
spoilers which leads me to you guessed
it audible I team up with audible all
the time because I think they are a
fantastic service audible is
offering all of you that are watching
this video a free 30-day trial with a
free download go to audible.com slash
grace or texts grace
Gerace EE 500 - 500 and you can download
a free title and start listening and on
top of that audible also has exclusives
and original audio shows I didn't know
that like I said I just downloaded call
me by your name because I am so curious
to hear how it compares to the movie
which is still processing so throw all
of the call you by your name on top of
me the other cool thing about audible
because if you're like me which is like
a dumb person I have a hard time
sometimes processing it audio in real
time audible now has speed control so
you can listen faster or slower or
whatever pace makes the most sense to
you how convenient is that so again go
sign up for your free 30-day trial with
a free download at audible.com slash
Grace that's audible.com slash g ra c e
or you can text grace grac e - 500 - 500
okay now back to the fashion side
Timothy chellamay has an effect on me I
got I got a pump the brakes Millie Bobbi
Brown
sorry I need a moment to take a sec ah
because you are every member of the
Spice Girls all-in-one and this is
adorable
we had a little scary spice with the
space buns baby spice with the baby pink
posh spice with the sequins subtle
ginger spice with the cape and some
sporty spice with the converse sneakers
look at you you've defied all fashion
categories cute Winona Ryder also from
stranger thing and it's very much trying
to tell us something she's sorry about
with her eyes did you shart
did you shart it's okay you still look
really really pretty doing it one of the
prettiest currently sharding people I've
ever seen cute Sally Hawkins who's from
shape of water which I also just saw and
guys I'm watching movies now and it's
taking a lot out of me it makes me tired
this is very retro and cute and there's
a lot happening this is like a magic eye
that points directly to your belly
button or I look directly into the Sun
there like seventies fruit stripe gum
it's also a really great dress for
people that don't want direct eye
contact because I can't get my eyes up
to your face
I've been I keep trying but still cute
Halle Berry this I dig I when do you age
you gonna give us a timeline on when
you'd like to start aging because that'd
be great getting exhausting being so
shocked at how ageless you are but also
very inspiring this is very like goth
prom queen cute mary j blige oh my god i
feel obliged to tell you that none of us
can compete this is like 2018 Swan Lake
or this like an episode of Project
Runway theme was like Sesame Street
meets sex yeah Reese Witherspoon this is
so damn elegant god dang it you this
color looks great on you you look like
the princess of Emerald City who's here
to say I've got clavicles yeah yeah
Saoirse Ronan
Saoirse Ronan steer sure I'm seriously
sorry that I am not pronouncing this
correctly I know but look here you are
what I meant to say pretty and demure
and it ended up with pure which I guess
isn't far off this looks nice on you
this looks elegant and high-fashion on
me this would look like just a diamond
map of where I'm currently sweating
under my dress cute Kate Hudson whoa you
look like you're baddest [ __ ] at the
country goth dance this is like
Westworld meets an Avril Lavigne music
video and I don't hate it this is like
some Queen and the Victorian age had a
daughter that loved Paramore cute Laura
Dern I love Laura Dern so much and gosh
darn it you look gorgeous this is also a
little Victorian Goffe but kind of
modern and sexy how dare you be able to
pull off all of those descriptive things
that I don't really even know what I'm
saying I'm just spouting a bunch of kind
of bullsh stuff but I have been
well-intentioned it's all
well-intentioned you're lovely and you
look lovely that was a journey cute got
a girl away she directed Lady burdens
getting a lot of critical acclaim
I enjoyed that movie very much you look
like you know those candy strips that
had the docks I'm gonna do like a you
know Punk
metal version of that candy and also
you're not giving those foot fetish
pervs what they want so get it girl
cute Nicole Kidman always looks goddang
stunning Congrats surprised you did it
again
this kind of looks like you were born
with this growth where you have a
bouquet of flowers coming out of your
shoulder that you can't get removed and
so you're like just put the dress over
it no one will know cute Allison Janney
dah dah stop but also go give me a
future space football business woman OH
damn dead yes yes yeah someone just one
adult prom in an episode of black mirror
and I'm for it cute Susan Sarandon I
loved so much I saw that there was some
mixed reviews about the sunglasses that
she wore her but get it girl
I heard that Sun was bright and would
you rather over photo like this or a
folder like this you're Susan Sarandon
you can do it are the you want wear flip
up sunglasses wear a hat wear some
sunscreen on your nose you do you Susan
yeah Margot Robbie I saw I Tania and oh
my god yeah I loved it so much how do I
recommend if you haven't seen it already
but I do like that this sort of is an
ice-skating inspired outfit it's like
they took an ice skaters Olympic outfit
and then just added more gown to the
bottom also wouldn't it be funny if this
is just how we found out that Margot
Robbie has some weird earth disease
where she grows hair just in a singular
strip around her upper abdomen would
really humanize her because she is
pretty perfect I know it's not true
unless you want to tell you something no
Yara Shahidi I know I'm probably saying
that totally incorrect and I apologize
but you look beautiful and you should
apologize you have made me insecure
because you look so stunning also when I
looked at this photo for a while I
thought you had some weird architectural
side of your pantsuit that just went out
like this and then I realized that's
just the arm on the wall behind you
either way cubism Belle this is
beautiful this color is so pretty you
look like a modern Cinderella weird like
a
that's like really showing up her
daughter on one of those episodes of my
super sweet 16 Tracee Ellis Ross ah dude
Alison Brie yeah you better breathe
leave it you you did it good sexy but
also still kind of feels 80s you look
kind of like a second wife to a guy
who's like a lawyer and you walked into
his law office Christmas party for the
first time and you were like I'm not
here to make friends
I'm here to make all of your wives
extraordinary jealous his children will
never love me and I'm okay with that
yeah Azen Williams this is beautiful you
look like a chandelier
you know the hourglass that shows up on
pieces when the computer freezes that
but like a Gatsby hourglass yeah Natalie
Dyer also from stranger things that also
looks outstandingly beautiful the top is
this kind of like sheer netting and then
the bottom looks like it has
astrological signs all over that's super
cool she looks like the kind of girl
like sneaks our whiskey into homecoming
in like a flask that's made out of
amethyst yeah okay there you go guys
there is my sag red carpet fashion
review I know I didn't get to a ton of
people that you probably wanna talk
about so leave your favorites in the
comments down below don't forget to
click subscribe to this YouTube channel
if you haven't already and make videos
Tuesdays and Thursdays for the time
being other than that I don't know no
how do you Timothy sha'lame no that's
not what I wanted but also am curious
about how do you pronounce Timothy
Shadowman